hey can you hear us now
it looks like it working hello that's
our da ting can you hear us now
who's we need confirmation from someone
this receipt for people who are watching
this video for the first time it must be
kind of weird and confusing for you but
that we're starting off this public
video this way yeah we were just live
there was about a hundred people there
we had no audio and now we have no one
here we're trying to find out if people
could hear us can you hear us right now
if you can hear us coming or hear us
comment now if you can hear us anyone
Fernando you said hello Anastasia yes
Amy yeah yeah you can hear us all right
well let's some people come in first and
then well we get this train rolling
rolling man and let's get this train
josh brolin ooh whoa yeah see what
happens in front of the contrast what
stronger the contrast I'm just saying
like if you drag it all the way to the
left we look crazy
what was that before 55 it was a
beautiful just there we go that's just
like people roll in and we're just now
I'm just gonna [ __ ] with you for now
blown out we have actual skin tone okay
so yeah we're gonna go over our top ten
list over here for most anticipated
movies of 2019 today it's a video say
2019 I think it said 2019 right the
first time it is about the second time I
don't recall yeah I have a habit of
still saying 2018 the way I I tend to
operate for some reason and I write
those checks right well yeah before we
happened in this John we haven't caught
up at all how's your day it's been great
so far I woke up fed your cats
then did a couple things on patreon and
then went to the coffeehouse and then
came back here looked up all the movies
of the year and we started this live
stream yeah so my day has been pretty
standard thus far how's your day been
okay said bed your cat's fed well I
don't fed the cat I don't want to be
presumptuous and I look I love the cats
and I my day is good I
last night after movie fights after
fighting damn Merle I had a pretty good
word cathartic at a pretty good
experience last night I had a very
experience that I learned so much from
it afterwards and it was so nice to
actually just chat with Dan for a while
afterwards and Greg you need to prepare
for Dan morosely wooden movie file it's
apparently it was last night the next
time you and I did no preparation I went
in just cold oh and off the top of my
head awesome I didn't even hear the
questions until it was live and so we
actually a blind fight would be a lot of
fun and so we but last night you know I
was I had worked out pretty much like
for ten days in a row so yesterday I was
like you know what I think I earned some
in-and-out burger
lucky duck so I went to in and out got a
burger fries got a little toke to milady
olive branch and then we we and then and
then I slept and now I'm here and I
think I'm gonna take the day off from
working out and just feel bloated all
day actually I don't feel so bloated
right now which is kind of rare for
after having a pretty big meal last
night well maybe it was a perfectly
proportioned to your cathartic victory
Thanks hey thanks Danny wick that's very
kind of you Danny wick official Oh
anyway visually man official it's very
kind of you good sir first time here
where's Ryan right he's in all of us and
he wants to be in you right I want Ryan
right to become the couch a chest of
Israel just like a an occasional cutaway
to you in the corner did anyone here in
this live stream actually watch the
movie fights last night if you did just
say
say yes don't wear weekend it's coming
first just comment ya cometh first right
there I guess no one hello purse thanks
Anastasia oh hey a pretty good amount of
you guys watch it any help on a breakup
well I'll tell you this much just feel
the pain and eventually you'll get over
it just gotta grieve last stage of grief
is acceptance to change share things
it's deceitful to get over any hope
look we're gonna happen to our list I
figured we should I'd rather get our
honorable mentions out of the way that I
don't want to deal with you know anyone
getting like pissed at me for why didn't
you mention this watch your surface if
you just because these are the honorable
mentions are gonna be the ones that I'm
like yeah that's uh that's something I'm
looking forward to but I have reasons
for why it's on my 10 knowing John and I
jump robably have like a gajillion I
have on I'll have like a small handful
that's the way it works and so I'll go
first
and then John will screw off for 10
minutes mine is I have four honorable
mentions here because these were the
ones that I contemplated put it on my
list there's actually one more I
contemplated put it on my list right now
here's the five that I I contemplated
and first one is uh I'll say is Toy
Story 4 yeah because I feel like Toy
Story 3 ended so perfectly that I like
getting to a toy store reform sure it'll
be fine sure it'll be good
simultaneously I'm like yeah I'm more
nervous than anticipate Ori I'm like
this is you wrapped it up so well and
we're gonna go back again yeah like yeah
I'm definitely gonna see it I'm
definitely looking forward to it yeah my
other one I guess would say lego movie 2
as an honorable mention it's that's very
kind of watching you next week and
Terminator 6 this was one that was
actually originally on my list see as
I'm someone who's been very much in
defense of the movie in terms of
everything I've been hearing about it
and I know that the franchise hasn't
been so great lately but in my opinion I
have some pretty strong faith that the
filmmakers behind it are really going to
do their absolute
best to make sure this is a good one
especially for this to be Tim Miller's
follow-up to Deadpool after the kids
after the whole fiasco that happened
with him not returning for Deadpool to
that meeting with Hollywood variety that
variety what interview I'm just I'm very
I'm very much excited for it this is not
on my top 10 funny enough another James
can produce pick Alita battle angel
which a lot of people think is gonna be
terrible I've been having some faith in
it and I heard the early reactions for
the movie have been fantastic and then
here's the one that I'm just telling you
guys right up front yeah is not in my
top 10 Star Wars Episode on I who after
all that last Jedi [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna
see it there's a lot of labor to wait
for to it but at the same time the last
Jedi became such a difficult experience
that like just I don't know fandom and
movies shouldn't have to be and so uh
yeah yeah nighttime a little bit like oh
let's just get it over yeah so I'm I'm
not I'm not really looking forward to
but I think there's made two cuts of
Star Wars Episode nine I feel like
that's the solution right there yeah
yeah the force will release some
simultaneous make the last Jedi fans cut
and the everybody else can both and what
else you got John
well I found out that they're making a
couple movies that I'm just excited to
hear that they're making really know
much about but they're making scary
stories to tell in the dark and are you
afraid of the dark which are too like
spooky things ones book and ones a TV
series that I was pretty excited about
and then I'll just rattle off a few
happy deathday to Hellboy curse of La
Llorona bright burn Godzilla king of the
monsters men in black far from home Lion
King in Chapter two stuff like that
Kingsman three you know seems like it
could be pretty fun missing link
I like claymation and stuff like that
Captain Marvel yeah that's probably the
the ones
care to like really shout out all right
yeah that's fun
Dean Smith reason that a prequel I have
no idea yeah that's a pretty cool right
is that you don't confirm that for being
the copy I would not be at all surprised
yeah I thought that was the one where
they were like they're going back in
time to learn about who the Kingsmen are
or something like that that could be fun
and oh there's a there's a captain
Marvel's on my list to four honorable
mentions I'm really looking forward to
that movie but it overall the top 10
most anticipated it's not there yes make
these all comic book movies and there's
also they're making a new Addams Family
and there's a zombie land to which I
feel I like Tom Beal and a lot so I'm
hoping fingers crossed
yeah it's alright and that's it Hellboy
is probably an honorable mention as well
but hey there's a lot of movies to look
forward to in 2019 a lot of big movies
and the funny thing that happens you put
together one of these lists is you use
at the beginning of the year or even we
are gonna [ __ ] on this earlier because
prior to having seen last I probably
would have a glass on the stylet of two
but a lot of times you know there are
trailers for movies that just haven't
come out yet in 2019 and often times
it'll be like Oh March debuted a trailer
for a movie I hadn't heard of now I'm
now this is one of the movies I really
want to see so yeah anyway spend enough
time beating around the bush with
building up ten minutes of enthusiasm to
get into the actual list let's get to
the actual list now John you want to go
first number ten yeah number ten the
intruder so excited to see Dennis Quaid
break into that house and terrorize
those beautiful people and you know do a
like view terrace but the other way
around I actually ordered these for
reals though in just release date order
so it looks so bad about the new
intruders movie but that Dennis quit is
how Dennis Quaid this really thinks this
is he's like giving he's so committed
he's so committed to it less and the
more committed he is like there's so
lack of self-awareness of the kind of
movie it's looking like
just makes it that much dumber I
actually am excited for this movie just
because I mean it looks so wacky and
it's the kind of movie that that usually
just goes off the rails with how kind of
silly it becomes in like Dennis Quaid's
ultimate commitment to this
ridiculousness is part of the charm plus
I love making good and that got good in
barbershop so that's fair that's a fair
point but for reals I did order these
just in release date order because so
I'm going with Alita first because I've
just I don't know for whatever reason
I've really been rooting for that movie
I know that the projections haven't been
good but the idea of Robert Rodriguez
and James Cameron kind of teaming up on
this passion project together excites me
I also am excited by the idea that
Rodriguez is getting a chance to work on
a giant scale again but with
collaborators who I feel like can bring
out the best in him also limiting some
of his indulgent tendencies and just
from especially everybody talks about
that last trailer we saw but especially
having looked up panels from the manga
and stuff and seeing that last trailer I
am excited to go to that world and I do
hope that that movie surprises everybody
and it's been kind of gratifying to see
the early reviews be so positive so hmm
I'm looking forward to that oddly enough
yeah I take what you say and put it a
little bit lower in terms of
anticipation and it makes an honorable
mention school for me number 10 would
have to be it chapter 2 I I was I really
liked the first it movie a lot I see the
cast list for it chapter two and I get
very excited at it I haven't read the
book but there seems to be a common
consensus if you've seen the miniseries
or if you've read the book that always
goes back to the same thing the stuff
with the kids is so much better than the
stuff with the adults so I'm really glad
I didn't shoot these two films
back-to-back to give it some breathing
room to give time to figure out what
worked with the first one to see what
they can properly do to make a good
sequel and probably is a good idea as
well because instead of shooting it
back-to-back you can make your movie
with you can you can have a box-office
success so that way it's easier to get
bigger
stars for your sequel I think I think
the people involved with it are gonna be
very much aware that people usually
respond to the adult stuff with it in
the book and the miniseries is not being
a really exciting element or being much
more lackluster compared to the stuff
with the kids so I think that for this
one it's number 10 only because I have
no clue who they'll deliver I I just
have this and it's more of an
anticipation of I really want to see
what they do with it and if they
ultimately will deliver it is like a
Dreamcast and then that way it is yeah
and yeah I kind of share your thoughts
and just knock that down a little bit
you got an honorable mention see yeah
that's fair I'm gonna rearrange this
list in real time to make this more
entertaining because you've ordered them
in an excitement order so next I'm gonna
go with beachbum I saw this trailer a
couple days ago and Harmony Korine is a
really device with filmmaker I Spring
Breakers is a weird-ass movie but it
really compelled me and seeing the
trailer for the peach bum it's another
one of those weird movies that just
looks out there and fever dream like but
what captivated me about that particular
trailer beyond all the crazy like
Linklater meets Harmony Korine stuff is
the way it switches halfway through to
like the party dream is over and it sort
of seemed like maybe Harmony Korine is
going to make us stride towards
something a bit more mature while he's
bringing his trademark indulgence to
this and it just kind of fascinated me
and with the way that like Spring
Breakers kind of came out of nowhere was
just like wow this is so gripping
I'm curious to see how that one pans out
you know I don't know I I had to include
an oddball on this list you know because
that's part of my taste and that's how
many Quran I feel like it will be
divisive as Harmony Korine tends to do I
personally am NOT the only one I've ever
seen as spring breakers and I was like
very much in the middle about it yeah
but you know that is more as more of
your flavor than it is mine and I'd say
so
it's a curiosity with
we're screen junkies it's it's more of
Spencer's flavor
les Dan's flavor I don't know yeah and I
Brad I approached this listing in an
excitement ranking order initially I put
that at 10 and Aleta at 9 but whatever
it's now I would say for number nine I'm
saying I'm going to put Shazam ass only
solely because of the fact that the
trailer out of all the big trailers for
Comic Con that was the one that stole
the show for me just because it was the
most surprising one like it in
retrospect looking over the Tris I feel
like there's some unique things to be
had you know you the comparisons are
like big meets Superman or keep coming
into mind with it it doesn't look
entirely unique in terms of a superhero
film like they're doing unique things or
doing different things but overall it
looks like you know a worthy fun
superhero film but there's something
about that that just seems so delightful
and charming and the fact that it's
trailer at comic-con managed to be the
the one that just genuinely surprised me
the most like yeah I'm really looking
forward to this film there and I have a
lot of high hopes for it as well I have
a lot of high hopes for this movie all
right well my number whatever this is
eight my number eight I I currently
considered this list because I knew that
we were gonna have a fair amount of
overlap and I also wanted to have some
genre diversity so this is a bit of a
left-field move but I'm gonna throw a
little on my list of anticipations just
because I'm a big Easter a fan I mean
I've been following insecure for a while
and and things like that and I'm really
psyched that Regina Hall has come back
because I feel like after scary movie
she just kind of disappeared and now
she's been back again in a big way and
especially with like what men want
coming out that doesn't look like it's
capitalizing on its repurposed premise
at all I feel like this movie actually
could deliver on that repurposed premise
I heard Mel Gibson shows up at the end
of that movie really no I mean in one
breath I wouldn't be so
and the other breath I just don't think
that would be enough to save it if it's
not already if he plays a satire version
of himself I bet he hears he hears his
thoughts and he wants to beat the [ __ ]
outta be like a rote comedy for an hour
in ten minutes in the last 20 minutes is
gonna be this really dark milk and
become talking about the media movements
yeah yeah yeah so yeah I don't know I
wanted to include something that cap
catched my caught my eye in the comedy
sphere and that's yeah what caught my
eye on the comedy sphere number a aid
for me oh wait a minute there's one I do
want to take out you know what I'm gonna
take out yeah I'm gonna take out this
one I okay yeah number eight I'm gonna
take out this one a replace I'm gonna
move bright bird to an honorable mention
only because I was thinking to myself
how cuz another movie popped in my mind
and I'm like now that movies definitely
on my top ten but but but bright burn is
but something tells me as much as I love
that trailer that the trailer is gonna
be better than the movie this is what I
that's the vibe I really pick up on with
that film is this is a cool idea and I'm
sure it'll be neat but I'm gonna replace
that right now with a movie that is
getting only a limited release in the
theaters and that is Martin Scorsese's
the Irishman that's movie that I don't
really see you next to Matt this year I
don't really see that on too many lists
but I I'm just as a guy who grew up on
Scorsese films
oh hell yeah who could I even consider
the best film of the 21st century to be
the departed which is somehow becomes
like most underrated movie I really do
love Scorsese films and I used to like
marathon Pacino and De Niro films and to
know that they're finally gonna be
sharing good amount of screen time
together not a few minutes and heat not
whatever that movie was Righteous Kill
but
helm of its like what other director
would you want them to share screen time
with as of this I really should be my
number one pick what other director
would you want them to share screen time
with other than Martin Scorsese like
that's the best director to be directed
by for these two actors and it's Al
Pacino's first movie with Scorsese he's
doing he's been like gank Aston a lot of
things and and Joe Pesci returned for
this movie this is a passion project for
Robert De Niro he's been trying to get
it off the ground for many years so
there's just so much passion involved in
this movie the thing that concerns me is
the is the D aging element of it that's
the part of it that I'm like is that
gonna look weird but you know I was out
for the being like a like a hundred to
two hundred million dollar budget
somewhere there and then seeing the
Captain Marvel trailer and and seeing
like you know I I never am thinking Sam
Jackson's D H I never think that when
I'm watching and granted Sam Jackson
looks amazing for his current age
whereas Pacino and De Niro look pretty
[ __ ] old I feel like I feel like
somehow though with lighting or whatever
they'll make it look really good you
know yeah I mean and in Scorsese's hands
I'm sure that they'll be enough around
it going on to make up for it even if
you can notice the aging tech or
whatever yeah and in in in light of all
this maybe take the beach bum off my
list and put the Irishman in there cuz
yeah I think Scorsese is one of the few
like masters who still like really has
got it yeah you know like even I know a
lot of people don't talk about this
movie but silence even his most recent
one was like really left an impression
on me yeah totally different kind of
movie and Saudia to see him coming back
with all these dudes it's like I didn't
think I could get excited for the
combination of these actors again
because I we saw Righteous Kill and
we've seen some of the other movies in
the vein of their old movies that
they've made lately but yeah the
Irishman is a very exciting voice but
guys you hear oh I'm playing right now
some girls do that's be reacts be react
we are subscribed to be reacts really is
a reaction channel that you guys should
go check out mm-hmm go check her out she
does great react and she's in this live
stream right now
so just wanted to show you out really
quick don't worry guys we'll be paying
more attention to what's going on in the
actual chat once we're Doug getting
through this list don't worry don't
worry you know he was have to work to
get our attention
mm-hmm I guess with Home Week oh yeah
we're very selective about who we care
yeah definitely you have to buy our love
it's all conditional number seven uh
what's your number seven my number seven
I am gonna go with a remake actually and
weirdly enough the first time we saw
this trailer I thought it was all right
and I saw it in theaters and it gripped
me a whole lot more than I thought it
would and I feel like this movie has the
potential to be the kind of remake
that's perhaps the crazies was where it
took something that had the potential
originally and then had some merits to
it and can bring it fully to fruition
are you talking about pets and I'm
talking about that Cemetery yeah I don't
know for some reason the translation
from small to the big screen when I
first saw the trailer on the big screen
I was like oh [ __ ] this really does look
intense and kind of creepy and I love
John Lithgow too in that role I didn't
think that you could recast I was when I
thought about that I think about that
movie I think about Fred Gwynne
which isn't what everybody thinks about
but I was like I was gonna be a weird
world to recast and they got John
Lithgow and I was like oh that's like
the Whitehead and thought of it but it's
like the one guy who could who could do
that and I'm a big fan of starry eyes
that those two guys made before that and
yeah I don't know for some reason it
just keeps sticking out in my mind and I
keep rooting for it because I think
that's a mid-tier Stephen King sort of a
cult movie the first one I only has like
a 55 on Rotten Tomatoes I've seen it
like it's there are definitely merits
but it's definitely dated and yeah I
feel like Pet Sematary could be pretty
cool all right yeah Godzilla king of the
monsters is my number seven really if
you have not seen that's a that I don't
know who made the trailer for the second
one mm-hmm I'm not by any stretch a
Godzilla like you know fanatic a it's
like I've seen more than I actually
heard like routine about the Godzilla
franchise but when I when I when I
see that trailer I its deliver that
second trailer especially delivers this
feeling of I've never been more excited
to watch monsters fight each other like
their suds it's like the few minutes of
a trailer does such a good job like it's
talking like a drum epic music building
up to this battle royale you're like oh
man really the trailers one of the best
trailers I see those iconic kaiju come
back together like well the music mixed
in and the way they build it up and the
editing of it it's it's just a great
[ __ ] trailer and then I show my
girlfriend that trailer on the phone and
she was like whoa I watched it we
watched it here yeah Wow then you watch
the trailer the theaters like it's like
no matter the scope you're watching that
trailer in it's like I don't know if the
movies gonna live up I don't but the
designs look amazing I'm sure it's gonna
be a total blast
I have no because oftentimes when I get
this excited for a movie of this caliber
it's like a the thing I'm looking
forward to it will deliver on but then I
kind of forget in my anticipation for it
that well if the stuff in between is
boring I'm not gonna like it as much I
that tense you know what I may have it's
kind of how it was with you know circa
movies like last year
Aquaman I wasn't like I wasn't in love
with the movie because of that factor
yeah and it's just like alcaman gave me
everything I wanted from the trailer but
then I watched moon like oh yeah but
there's things in between that I didn't
anticipate that I wouldn't really care
for so if Godzilla can at least make
good on the other stuff and then really
deliver then I feel like it's gonna be a
great film but in terms of a theater
experience Godzilla's the one that one
of the top oh yeah definitely I feel
like that that was one I deliberated
pretty hard on including or not on this
list the next one for me is a movie that
you have already talked about and it's
Shazam because that also was the biggest
surprise of comic-con for me I I really
enjoyed that trailer I've enjoyed the
little peeks we've gotten at it since I
like
it represents for what DC is trying to
do there seems like they're broadening
out a little bit and I'm a fan of David
Sandberg who made lights out both the
short and the film yeah yeah and Annabel
creation creation yeah so uh it looks
terrifying all the stuff that you say
yeah looks really scary isn't it so you
know Suzie bows number six on my list is
this I don't know if this is on Jon's
list I think this is at the same spot
yeah I think this will be my next movie
if I'm then we'll just riff nine number
six pick the more I hear about this
movie and the more footage and pictures
and even the behind the scenes
shenanigans that I've heard about I I
couldn't help but I can't help but be
like just I gotta I gotta see what this
movie is I have zero I have zero
my heart is I'm like this I'm really
50/50 on it is it gonna be good it's bad
I don't know I just don't know
regardless I haven't feel like it's
gonna be [ __ ] interesting that is
Joaquin Phoenix is a joker but he'll
yeah if you turn from todd phillips
joker movie into Joaquin Phoenix's Joker
and what is exciting to me about that is
that combination because Todd Phillips I
think has something to prove a little
bit because yeah he's his most acclaimed
thing is the first hangover and then
like things got kind of sour from there
and then war dogs is OK from what I
understand but this seems like a huge
opportunity to do something in an arena
that is a Wild West right now like the
seu is just kind of a wild west to me
and yeah to see an older actor of
caliber step into the role in the
Joker's like so exciting and the kind of
Scorsese vibe they keep talking about
like this is the other side of what
excites me about what DC is trying to do
now is like Shazam is this really fun
thing that that has you know more of a
youth accessible element and then this
is the more like adults I perceive it
yeah well my number 5 I'll take the lead
now component my number 5 will be I was
always looking forward to it and then I
saw the trailer for this
moving and it I got even like a billion
times more excited for it and that would
be spider-man far from home I think that
the how do I put it man I mean we
already like talked about it so much
within 20 minutes of like this huge
mysterious yeah it got me very excited
for that element of course the variety
of spider-man suits in it I do think the
cinematography in the film looks updated
I feel like it's its colors pop a lot
more is it as striking visually as Sam
Raimi's movies no like a basis based off
the trailers it doesn't look to be
delivering on that end but it seems like
there's an actual style to it I don't
feel like I feel like the homecoming had
a rarely unique tone to the movie but in
terms of a visual flair I didn't really
feel that whereas in this trailer so
many moments just have that famous
moment where he's just like [ __ ]
flying yeah yes and then you even the
Mysterio a like that seems to be there's
a production design quality to it that's
got me a lot more excited the you know
as much as we'd like there's as much as
I want Santa Loma moves to be a
standalone as possible I'm never really
as bothered with the inclusion of Nick
Fury because I don't feel like we're
ever gonna have like a Nick Fury
standalone movie yeah he's yeah he's a
supporting character always yeah he's
always a supporting character he's a
good thread to keep in mind and in a lot
of ways I actually prefer him to be in
the movie as opposed to Iron Man which
everyone's like a surgeon I prefer Nick
Fury in there and Jake Gyllenhaal he's
gonna be a bad guy yeah either by the
end of this movie it'll be reveal or
he's gonna be a bad guy no later on I
don't [ __ ] know either way kick
Gyllenhaal on one of these movies he's
one of the most underrated actors around
right now and he's been turning him down
for years you know yeah yeah so I'm very
much on to what I'm what I didn't hone
in on as much the first time we watched
the trailer but since I've kind of
picked up and people have pointed out is
there's like a espionage spy kind of
undercurrent to some of the imagery in
the trailer like you got him and Nick
ostensibly in this boat you know like on
a canal which is very like espionage
movie type of thing and those shots of
Nick Fury like looking out over the city
the glass building yeah so III liked you
know the first one brought in like a
John Hughes element and so I'm excited
to see this genre smash now yeah yeah
just just to piggyback yeah my next
choice I'm leaving piggyback and John
you don't believe in piggyback believe
in riffing well my number four choice I
don't know if this is gonna upset people
in in its placement but I don't know I
think it's alright number four I am
going with what's probably everybody's
number one it's a Avengers end game
because sorry you know I'm not gonna not
see how all this ends and I mean you
know you know how I feel about comic
book movies I like them the other half
gets snapped away just yeah and they're
just gone forever and this is an
alternate universe as far from home
takes place Kevin Feige shows up and
says far from home was a fake trailer
that we shot just to mislead you yeah
ending and we are bankrupt yeah no more
black panther sequels that's why we got
that Best Picture we killed black we
kill Black Panther it's it's ending I'm
sorry guys Kevin Feige for an hour and
50 minutes going no this is why we
decided to kill all these characters and
go home see in phase 5 but yeah I don't
know endgame is that trailer I really
like the approach they took with the
trailers not just about what the status
of the movie is and all the anticipation
like I like the restraint that they
brought to that trailer and the weird
it's funny everybody gets really uptight
about the idea of you know dark or
serious subject matter in superhero
movies because it didn't pan out as well
as everybody hoped it would for some of
DC's stuff but I feel like they have a
good approach to the somber attitude
because they made a really big
impression with the way they used the
sombre elements of infinity war and so
yeah going into endgame I'm very both
excited and fascinated to see how this
all wraps up because I feel like
Avengers infinity war and by proxy and
game I hope
are kind of special movies for this
genre because they did manage to feel
like kind of an earth-shattering event
amid a series of films where every film
centers around an earth-shattering event
you know mm-hmm so yeah very very
anticipating very much anticipating a
infinity War part 2 endgame I'm excited
for that too yeah my number 4 pick would
have to I saw this I was away in
Colorado when the trailer debut so John
have to cover this on his own I watched
this trailer and it was one of those
feelings where I was like man I wish I
had done a reaction for this because it
I watched on my phone with headphones on
outside it during the day and I was
still like what the [ __ ] and that is the
Jordan peels the movie us I I think get
out is a is a fantastic movie I'm kind
of annoyed by the public reaction
following get out oh you have how Jordan
Peele is the most talked about horror
movie guru of all time and all the
sudden it seems like every month I got a
new thing I'm hearing about with Jordan
peels produced this Jordan peels
producing this as always like horror
horror or Jordan feeling like he's made
one movie right now one great horror
movie it's a fantastic one and a lot of
ways a monumental one especially
considering the Oscar when he had for
writing so yeah but the the thing about
us is you know because of the amount of
Jordan Peele hype that has now been
created with that film I'm kind of
worried for how the reactions gonna be
for me of it even though I'm not a big
fan of glass I kind of feel like this
could be his kind of glass movie or his
unbreakable follow up to six cents
because this looks so much weirder and
at least the trailers prepping you for
that it did that this is gonna be a lot
stranger this is not like to me the only
thing that's in the vein of get out is
it's about black
they don't have they don't have some
social element very sure but it's not
gonna be the same kind of movie and I
feel I'm looking I love the trailer for
it it's just I ever kind of kind of feel
like people are gonna go into it and
just get out there's a portal to get out
it's better to get out and I just am NOT
looking forward at that side of it dan
Seibert sorry to interrupt you but Dan's
here Dan's here yeah hate that guy no
gosh what what is what is this little
invitation Dan don't worry I covered it
nodes there my bad I cover the wrong
side oh [ __ ] yeah hopefully you guys
didn't see that look you do look what's
this invitation dan you and your wife's
let's do it unless wedding what's doing
an enveloping that's alright they can
all just show up at the wedding so yeah
I mean other than that worried part to
it
the us trailer looks insanely unique I
feel like when you go kind of weird and
really out there in such a strange way
the genre that were that most appeals to
me is when you do it in horror mhm
beyond anything else like it because I
feel like it most naturally lends itself
there because horror hinges so basically
on fear of the unknown and that are
weird or hard to understand yeah I got
like weird and strange things but the
but the main thing I love that in is
horror movie just this it was amazing
and I feel like he's upped his game in
terms of visual palette no would that
film - oh yeah good call um hey I think
we can unite a little bit coming up my
number three is a is a part three I'm
looking forward to John wick chapter
three Parabellum because that [ __ ]
trailer was wicked those those pictures
of him on the horse were wicked wicked
haha now no pun is my number 32 so yeah
no no I build that up here
ya know that's why I said we will get to
be men with the Bensons with the
mechanical prints but yeah I don't know
I mean John wick the first one is so
kind of straightforward in one way but
so distinct in another way and and even
though I didn't like chapter two quite
as much I am really compelled by this
series I think the action always stands
out is always bone-crunching
impressively tactical impressively
choreographed you like it there's a lot
of ingenuity that goes into these movies
and I feel like you know the hype based
off of just what the filmmakers are said
and what the trailer looks like as well
as you know some early reactions I'm
really hoping that this becomes like a
beautifully told trilogy I know a couple
of people who saw an early screening of
it I cannot say who they are because
that would be bad but a couple of people
who saw it and I very much value their
opinions rare do I disagree with them
usually we see very eye to eye on things
and they said that it was their favor
one of the franchise yes yeah that's um
I always don't know they don't think
part two is better than part one they
said this one's the best one yeah I'm so
excited yeah yeah that's the thing you
know I always get a little more nervous
every installment of something I like we
get yeah I like the just the stakes get
that much higher but I don't know
there's something about the John wick
films that seems a little special I mean
Keanu Reeves is so committed seems like
just everyone loves making them and
everyone loves watching them but yeah
and that's kind of magical you know so
I'm really excited for them
my my my the way Craig said looked like
it was the worst what which one oh he's
talking about a judge on my second movie
that I'm most looking forward to this is
this was like a no brainer for me I was
like weirdly this I feel like this has
the potential of my favorite movie of
the year even though it's my number two
most anticipated as there's different
reasons for anticipation as opposed to
what I actually think will be my the
is but most scientists the second most
anticipated I would have to say once I
went to time in Hollywood
you put that dance my number to number
two okay then what we don't know what is
I feel like what men want
yeah my actually there were there were
photos just released today that look
incredible of this movie just okay puts
off its Tarantino taking a step back
into not not the present time but you
know only like 40 years ago as opposed
to the Western time yeah it's not that
yeah because you kept going like further
and further back you know it's and in
this movie you know you got DiCaprio
he's reunited with Brad Pitt he's
reunited with you Brad Pitt and DiCaprio
in the same movie is so exciting to me
they have this image a release with too
near enough Turner with with the
Catherine Rio rapid and Al Pacino it's
like damn that looks crazy Margot Robbie
as Sharon Tate this are the images have
released it just looks like a very
vibrant film and him dealing with a
sensitive subject like this it's when
the way it was announced it sounds like
it's not really about what people
thought it was originally about you know
well yeah something Charles Manson's
story yeah yeah like everyone said is
making Charles Manson movie and some
things about people and it just happens
to be around the time of that you know
yes and the what just Tarantino's my my
favorite screenwriter of all time like
he do I think he's is like wild and
crazy as someone like a Charlie Kaufman
no I like I love Charlie Kaufman films a
lot but in terms of a writer Tarantino's
my favorite one and does this what you
doing these with this cast together and
this time period and also the subject of
like once upon a time in Hollywood like
one of the cool things like Tarantino
and Kevin Smith they have this very film
buff personality it's
because there's a lot of cinephiles you
know a lot of big-time directors and
writers are obviously cinephiles and
movie buffs but you don't really
associate their personality to be film
buff yeah Tarantino is film buff yeah so
to have this movie that revolves around
a very specific time in Hollywood in an
earlier decade where times were so much
different but we can still like you know
find it a little tangible yeah because
it's not too distant from us yeah I I'm
very much looking forward at this but
I'm excited to see what he does with it
man it's it sounds sounds [ __ ] weird
and cool yeah for that I mean the thing
is like in the mythology of Tarantino's
filmography he says he wants to make a
finite amount of narrative motion
pictures and this seems to be at least
toward the later side of whatever that
number ends up being and and he said you
know like after this I may make
documentaries or do like histories on
Hollywood and so I feel like so much of
his filmography up until this point has
been him using his you know cinephile
Inklings to explore his love of
different genres but I'm excited now to
see him he must be an expert on
Hollywood and you see him make a movie
that seems like it's just about life in
Hollywood at the time and a time that he
clearly seems to draw a lot of
inspiration from that is fascinating to
me because yeah it's a bit more grounded
in reality at least from the outside it
seems like it would be and yeah I'm
fascinated to see him use this side of
his you know you know they call it
playing to your the top of your
intelligence using the things you know
really well about and yeah I'm excited
to see him bring this historical element
after he's done you know so many
historical fictions yeah totally yeah
what's your number one my number one
pick is is is what men know it's uh yeah
yeah yeah and then I feel like a lot of
the things you said are super valid I
mean every time somebody like comes out
and like really impresses people just
everyone freaks out and it's the only
name you hear it's like for a while it
seemed like everybody thought that II
drew selva was the only black actor or
like Jennifer Lawrence is the only
actress it's just like we love her now
casts her in every
that top party should be casted every
role and so yeah I do kind of get the
fatigue on that about like okay like I
love get out to I respect this guy's
work a lot but yeah let's see what he
follows up with and so I'm just excited
to see him do his thing and to make this
follow up because I don't know I have a
feeling that he you know there's got to
be a lot of hype there's got to be a lot
of expectations but I feel like he can
walk in and just do his thing and yeah
the the trailer I didn't really know
what to expect coming out of get out for
a follow up but I was gripped that whole
time like it looks totally jarring but
also very different and I like to that
you're getting
Winston Duke and Lupita Nyong'o
I mean this is a genre movie it's gonna
go crazy but I like that they're
actually just getting to play a normal
couple for a hot minute you know to play
actual characters before they have to do
this horror scenario and it seems
fascinating for them because they'll get
to play two sets of characters and all
that and yeah I'm just a big fan of a
horror and be things that are surreal
and twisted and unsettling and things
with kind of hidden symbols and I feel
like this movie's gonna have a lot of
that hidden symbology a lot of that
social age that Jordan Peele seems to
have a vested interest in and as a
horror fan as a genre fan I love when
you can have a great suspenseful
affective sensory horror movie that also
has a lot on its mind and a lot in its
heart and I feel like Jordan Peele can
kind of do all three at least if get out
is a standard is a bar and so yeah I'm
super excited for us I'm really hoping
he nails it yeah it's gonna be good I
don't know who's gonna great my number
one x-men Dark Phoenix man new mutant a
new mutants on Hulu I like last year I
might have put new mutants on this list
before all this other stuff have this
done now I've now that I'm here it's
possibly order Hulu I've reached a super
concerned no my number one is my number
one I was gay it is a vendor's endgame
but the thing is I don't anticipate that
it will actually be my favorite
movie of the year that's a weird part to
this list because I but the thing is
it's the one I'm without a doubt the
most anticipated and hopeful for that
they nail it because this this could be
the defining moment when Marvel gets it
wrong really
there's so much because to me this could
be the return of the king I know there's
not three you know
danos let villain movies or something
but it can be there Return of the King
in a lot of ways because as exciting as
the MCU films are and as much as I often
love them and I Black Panther was one of
my favorite movies of last year for
movies about superheroes I rarely
actually get that feeling when you get
to the finale beyond this is really cool
and exciting too and I feel like with
all they've done with leading up to this
I feel like we could be in that seat
being like having that that real that's
like we we know though some of these
heroes will succeed we have a friend
that's probably going to be some finite
deaths in this specific installment but
there's I really I really just because
that is the biggest set of stakes it is
without a doubt the most hyped movie of
the year
fortunately infinity war the most hype
movie of last year managed to like did a
great job Tomales yeah and it managed to
not be like just easily that is fine but
it still got everybody yeah like and
then this installment I'm like I think
there's even more space now because
infinity more stuck the landing
because there's something audacious and
now they have to pay it off yeah because
and then they got it
with the whole the whole idea of the
characters coming back that's one time
and people are gonna be looking copy you
know if you were gonna say [ __ ] like
that they gotta have a good really have
to have them they have to nail that in a
way we're not like Bowery and you know
they gotta earn it
yeah they have to have so much to earn
they have to stick because they Alice
they don't do this that they don't make
people like this could be the time where
people are like questioning Marvel now
you know and this there's with so much
at stake it's not one of those cases
where I'm like [ __ ] MC he's got this
yeah I feel like they will overall but
there is that slight tingle in my heart
that goes yeah yeah this is a crazy
crazy task and I'm also looking forward
to that Return of the King finale
feeling in terms of like my hopeful side
is having that first mark because I
can't think of another Marvel movie
where I really had that you know by the
time Black Panther gets the fighting
kill monger you're like this is gonna be
excited in cool and we know he's got
this and I wanted them win best part we
know it would be kind of yeah that's
just a weird thing about these these
movies it's act 3 reminds you that oh
it's a Supergirl
yeah actors usually like oh this is when
the coolest actions gonna come in or
something like that you know whereas as
in this one I I feel like we can finally
get that real triumphant feeling well
yeah this is their epic as it feels like
to me like their true Lord of the Rings
I think is a good mark of comparison
because that is also like an epic yeah
epic war movie yeah that's essentially
what they're doing with infinity war so
so yeah I mean I do I honestly think
it'll be my favorite movie of the year
I I think you'll I don't think it will I
think it'll give us a lot to talk about
I think I'll give us a lot to talk about
ya know the reaction these these guys
you gotta check out this true because
there's five seconds of Tony Stark
punching a guy bunch of in the last row
after a while I was like oh just check
out anything that's a lots of things
happen so yeah because yeah last year
you know last year I would say it Fedor
was almost hype movie but a star is born
to be my favorite movie last year so you
never know what's gonna move you the
most and an anticipation is a weird
thing to yeah because I yeah I don't
know the expectation and delivery or two
things so but yeah guys those are our
top 10 lists right here how's it going
in the comments we'll be here for just a
few more minutes
yes you're questioning now we figured
like an hour is a good amount of time to
do these things yeah and so yeah eight
minutes people make it count
what's your unpopular movie you're
looking forward to Terminator and
Mikhail Linden's here Mikkel one of our
favorite patrons how's it going guys
buddy Anastasia wants to know are you
guys roommates yeah maybe yeah yeah yeah
we spoon at night yeah he's big spoon
roommates
roomies roommates who live in the same
home I've yet to see his balls oh that's
not true
yeah probably at some point it happens
yeah I just don't say anything
I've seen your equipment but it was a
while ago yeah I think I've been touched
by your equipment at least a one touched
by your acquit mint touch my Nicole that
trailer for Extremely wick is shockingly
evil and vile movie about Ted Bundy drop
today well you see the thing is the
second we put that into title they're
going to make sure they're going to take
money from yellow dollar bill that
here's how it always goes right like the
Mortal Kombat videos for example the
reason we don't cut those up is because
we're like we know they're not going to
be monetized you know like you'll see a
lot of our videos where the before and
after the reaction is very much like
edited and like they'll take a long time
a lot of those like especially the
discussion-based ones take a long time
to actually slice up you know
and then for something like that I would
want to edit it and the problem is is
that the site you put that in the title
you get a yellow dollar bill sign and
then after it's done accumulating all
the views it's good yeah you you request
them to go and manually and be like wait
a minute is this appropriate my time
they get around to that your video is
about its course yeah it's run its
course and then it's like you've done
hours of work to make $4 - it doesn't
actually move you to upload a million
times a day so we got to be more
conservative that's that's the other
thing too is like you can't you can't
just you can't do all these like crazy
that's why we upload less now you know
we've got to learn a lot from people who
are more connected to the will involve
with algorithms and YouTube so we can't
really do it we can't put up as many
videos yeah anymore if somebody asked
what your unpopular anticipation choices
and I honestly mean the intruder
every year there's like a bad movie that
I just really hope I get to see and
that's the lunch
yeah that one but Nicole I I'm letting
you know I I don't really have Zach
Efron has Ted Bundy just a feeling
I'm fascinated whereas I select soon as
I actually love Zach I actually love
letters I I'm actually a really big Zac
Efron thing I'm not I have no I'm
nowhere near on the Zac Efron hatred I
was prior to movies like neighbors
honestly boy yeah because just as a
pretty boy to me yeah that's that seems
to be the hey Amy how's it going in
Kuwait there seems to be the one we're
talking about Zac Efron yeah oh this is
the one thing I tend to hate like I just
automatically don't like is when a guy
is famous for like when I just feel like
he's just a pretty boy and he's
not really that good of a talent in the
other areas that can really annoy me
with when people get famous for stuff
like that so I usually I mean boy bands
what's weird is boy bands I've kind of
grown more respect for ya because I'm
like now they're still talented I used
to hate like NSYNC and Backstreet Boy
record of like well that lifestyle like
Owens your life oh yeah they are dancers
and their sing or some like I can't say
that about them have to be vaguely
pretty because they're singing generic
yeah so I would definitely say that
hello to India somebody requested that
we do one Indian video week I saw that
maybe perhaps perhaps we did talk about
a of chapter two you'll have to go back
through the video hey Charlotte
Charlotte's here yay
what's up char I liked him in that movie
channel 17 you see I think Zac Efron's
like great in comedy and even in that
bum beach bum trailer I'm like Jeff
almost cool in this movie yeah and I
feel like that's a good role for him but
but I do for some reason him as Ted
Bundy I'm like I don't think I'll ever
be able to see past the guy in front
like in a way it reminds me making Chloe
Moretz carry where I'm like you might do
a good job man but I don't know if I'm
ever gonna lose you into this role yeah
but I'm curious to see who we got here
thanks Emilio estévez I Dom my
girlfriend likes you she sounds like
she's got good taste about time you guys
wait let's three-way going yeah let's
let's do that who do you think Tony will
save an end game happy she's gonna be
like take take care of the guy in the
spider suit he's gonna die oh yeah I
don't know if anybody's gonna ultimately
save Tony an end game no we didn't
really think Tony who you think oh well
sale say am i bad happy she was busy
right in that big ass yeah we did
mention star was episode 9 on our
honorable mentions because because
and yeah the last Jedi was it yeah oh
yeah oh you know I'm gonna take time to
talk about that Ghostbusters 3 teaser
trailer right here hey if you guys
finally wanna
Saburo there are a lot of people asking
for it and frankly I was like you know
I'm not going to react to what is
essentially an Instagram could have been
a moving picture picture like there's
really nothing
to that I'm like I don't see the point
in doing a reaction to this and I've
actually just watched it and I was like
okay sure
oh you mean ecto one's gonna be in this
movie like if you guys want us to it's
like he gives you nothing to go off
we're not even sure who's in it we're
not even sure with like we have no clue
what they're doing with it well yeah I
all I know is they're giving it to you
know Jason Reitman and I don't yeah and
they're like just because he just makes
good movies
he's December this kind of raise the son
of the guy who helmed it yeah I I just
like sure it'll be fine
yeah I thought ghostbusters females we
find through the call - I thought that
was I thought that was fine yeah that
was fine the thing is is like the only
the only great one in my personal
opinion is the first Ghostbusters movie
and it wasn't like this long-lasting
franchise it's like it's it's gone on
through like cartoons and video games
and video games that are not things that
are it's not like they got the whole
original cast back to the cartoon and
all these things and and - Ghostbusters
- was alright I've seen that I've seen
Ghostbusters - several times and I'm
always like it is alright yeah yeah and
then the Ghostbusters remake is it's
alright
yeah and I don't I don't understand em
and we're supposed to do a video on this
later this month sometimes
fandom can really just be such an
off-putting element to why I'm not
really caring about it because weirdly
it's I I could have a I feel like we can
have like a great discussion on the
meaning of Star Wars fandom and why that
touches so many people's lives I have
the hardest time truly deciphering why
dan Aykroyd written comedy why that is
like why did we treat this like it was a
sacred text even if you love the second
Ghostbusters movie you know even if you
love that movie
I I don't I'm like at the end of the day
it's only real intent is to entertain
you with some slight horror thrills but
primarily make you laugh III don't think
it's as crazy mythological bill thing
with characters that are more than just
hey Harold Raimi's is the smart one Bill
Murray's the funny sarcastic one dan
Aykroyd is somewhere in between that
they're not booking Luke Skywalker
Princess Lea you know they are it's not
a great excuse to do certain things
that's my big thing about this movie as
I heard the announcement and I was half
my brain went oh that's neat you know
they're gonna give it to the son of the
guy I'm sure he'll do a good job I've
seen a few of his movies and I like them
and the teaser is cool but yeah like
what is that a shot even in the [ __ ]
movie I bet not I am I doubt it
have they even shot you know I can reach
of something that they shot specifically
as an announcement to get people excited
I doubt they've even got a script Jason
right ready
the second unit [ __ ] you know that they
probably hired an agency to make or
something I don't know but uh but yeah I
don't know all I can think of
having seen that teasers like yeah this
is cool and all the problem is that when
answer the call came out you know again
piggybacking off what you were getting
into just yeah the the way everybody
started to behave around that movie kind
of broke ghostbusters for me because I
was just like there's there's no reason
that Ghostbusters should elicit this
kind of ugliness in any context yeah
even if you don't like the casting even
if you don't like the approach even if
the director is mouthing off at you like
there's no reason we all should be
behaving in this ugly way about this
movie when it's really not that big of a
deal either way yeah and so it kind of
it's like I don't even really want to go
back and watch Ghostbusters again
anytime soon because I'm just I'm sick
of that taste that it left in my mouth
and so I feel like this new Ghostbusters
movie is exactly what everybody wants
and that's a neat thing in one way but
the problem for me is it just starts to
ultimately feel like I witnessed a
temper tantrum that got rewarded with
ice cream you know yeah cuz everybody
threw a fit about what answer the call
became and it also wasn't a huge
financial success so you know now we get
this idealized version that is could be
cool could be pandering I don't know if
they do some kind of torch pass I'm
gonna give the movie the benefit of the
doubt either way but honestly I'm gonna
wait till I'm in the theater to have any
thoughts on and other than these because
I'm just kind of sick of it oh yeah you
know I mean like the rage and verbal
abuse that comes from the toxicity like
sure they're Oh evidently we don't care
about ghostbusters as much as other
people do i watch the [ __ ] out of it
girl I love the first one like the first
one is a classic that's a great one but
that I did toxicity that comes from it
I'm just like guys it's it's there is an
unexplained ghost [ __ ] in that first
movie it's like if they did a hangover
for
like use a [ __ ] or the first million
amazing get out of the glory days it was
the 80s we get it like do some new oh
zeroing out 10 bucks Larry's thanks man
thank you so much is 10 times what we
would make from working hours on a
cutting up that Zac Efron's right maybe
we'll do it now even if people who
they're super chaps will do that Zac
Efron to make up Damien Castro just
wanted to say hey and I miss hhn dearly
as well I missed all of you guys thank
you sir hang out that's very kind very
kind of you indeed preach people think
like especially with the trailer ones
you know it's like the truth like we've
made a new rule of thumb that for when
it comes to like it's like it really
needs to get out right away like John
wick or spider-man far from home even
those for mi5 chrome had a sketch that
we spent it's funny that that's guys so
II like 55 seconds long but that took
about an hour to shoot and then about
two and a half hours yeah it took like I
had to cancel some should be like no
they're concentrators coming out but
like for the other trailers though it's
like we don't have time to edit this
it's like no one else is going to so
let's get it up you know let's make sure
we really give a review and be shark
when we're doing it but for the before
the like we don't just react and say
subscribe so we like to you know make
sure that our time is being valuable
here and so yeah if we talk about like
how doing that just wouldn't be
cost-efficient and we and if we simply
don't care enough about the movie we're
just probably not gonna do it especially
with the way algorithm works now it's
the way it is
yeah you know we only have so many
upload slots a day now so we can't just
do everything and yeah yeah that's why
it's like we did have the patreon to for
that rewards here as well because
there's always requests coming in so
it's like well this will satisfy like
the hardcore fans as well of the channel
but then also you know we primarily do
still stick with what we want to do
fix the court
HM Tamar's Nicole gets I feel I feel
like we've seen her name on on patreon -
yeah no never message each other but
have you seen her name and like comments
or anything
John usually like Adriana I am of the
messages feel like I've seen you at
least in the likes and stuff
Nicole you know it's really interactive
here I feel like well tell you what all
this is playing right now
yeah let's do it live right now if you
happen to stay here til the end of the
video it's just mrs. play right now it's
Nicole has after the $10 that that's
fine I'm just gonna Google eyes back and
Ted Bundy that's extremely shocking and
incredibly evil whose honor as our
notification sorry for the beginning
here we go we're gonna full-screen this
now the video is going to be demonic
eyes because the company's alright if
they manually review Chucky be on your
worst nightmare
[Music]
you actually believe this garbage look
how cool I looks like you know it looks
like a case I feel like it it'd be easy
to judge this movie based off of the
trailer yeah I feel like it easy to
judge it based off of the idea of like
oh it's a movie that's glorifying a
killer yeah in that capacity you know
but I really feel like that's a case of
marketing
JT sorry hey JT what should you be at
screen junkies right now working man
yeah yeah I'm back on the board
alright I've got a watch yeah and it's
kind of I haven't seen the movie vice
but it kind of has that attitude yeah
I'm just like oh another movie about a
horrible guy it's like really cool is
edgy it is yeah and I don't I just don't
the thing is I don't feel like Zac Efron
is gonna do a bad job in that he looks
insanely committed and he died you know
I I said that thing about not losing him
and I don't know if I would but his look
at
Ted Bundy the more it went on I was like
oh okay I get why he got cast with it I
would still it's the kind of thing where
I'd be like look what Zac Efron is doing
yeah Zac Efron's doing a good job I feel
like I would just be constantly
reminding myself like I don't feel like
I personally maybe saw a lot of you guys
will be able to I feel like I would I
would just be still aware especially for
a tenth and this okay for something's
been a lot of like Ted Bundy dick movies
there been a lot of movies made but it's
like at least the thing I'll give it
credit for is it looks like it's trying
to do something a little bit different
with its its tone at least yeah but and
it looks like it's trying to at least
maybe explore a little bit of just his
life and not only going let's watch him
kill a lot of people and weirdly weirdly
as much as I could hop on the bandwagon
side of Ted Bundy did these horrible
things and this is a trailer that's
glorifying him the part of the things
that made Ted Bundy so unique from from
my memory of this because clearly we did
- one of the things I made 10 buddies so
unique in terms of being a very popular
serial killer was how like people seem
to really love it he's charming he was
handsome he was articulate I've seen
those courtroom scenes or the things I
remember hearing about Ted Bundy the
count like a lot of serial killers got
letters and stuff it's head-butting
especially God the love letters through
Warner marry and they thought it was a
really good-looking guy I thought it was
very charming
so exploring this element of the
manipulator of beyond like yeah we know
he's a crazy [ __ ] psychopathic serial
killer but exploring the the manipulator
side of him and how he able to love him
and the charm yeah is it element I think
is is intriguing in a certain aspect I
still I'm kind of like near why is it
gonna is it really gonna deliver on that
or is it gonna try to meet this like
hybrid kind of like that that thing
where it's like oh we wanted
that side but also really show her he's
like a [ __ ] up Suriya yeah I feel like
this is one of those subgenres that's I
think really hard to get because there
are just so many not good movies about
actual serial killers and I feel like
serial killer biopic is kind of like
video game movie in the way that we're
still trying to get one that's like
truly great like the best one is a
fiction is you know Henry the portrait
of serial killer
pause Lisa thanks for being here she
came from movie fights thank you yeah
and Charlotte we have definitely noticed
you and Charlotte makes a great point
say I've always kind of a curious to do
reaction certain reactions live because
I like to see like a media people are
saying and girls and guys having a crush
on Ted buddy again is Duffy not what we
need yeah and as much as I don't ever
really think about will a movie
influence an audience there are there
are people who are it might not be the
majority of people who yeah but there
usually is a little bit of people who
sometimes blame a movie or something for
why they turned out a certain way and I
would say that is a point because
already Ted Bunny was someone who was
very much beloved it in a weird
fucked-up way he was someone who people
really loved everyone you know there are
still people protesting I noticed you
Jenner end up so yeah people are saying
so yeah and the only asterisk I would
add to that as Zodiac isn't a biopic of
that guy it's about the people who are
working on that case whereas this is Ted
Bundy is like the central we will spend
time with him figure and the thing about
this is yeah like I don't love serial
killer culture I know there are people
who eat up more crime zeroing out whoa
crazy
much appreciated seriously you're
[ __ ] awesome uh yeah I don't know
five nipples for you buddy
oh no fine nipple for ya how Ted Bundy
got love oh yeah so if you
look look at my look at my nipple right
here why aren't you glad he came from
movies and frivolous non-functional
anyway anyway yeah I think zero thank
you thanks for being here buddy
for anything that's so super guy I don't
love serial killer culture I know there
are a lot of people who like really eat
up true crime and who do like just
immerse themselves in the lives and like
Charles Manson or whoever that being
said I out of all the serial killers out
there I have often found Ted Bundy to be
one of the most fascinating because of
the contrasts that lived in that mind
and so the idea of a Ted Bundy movie is
appealing and interesting to me I don't
necessarily love the tone that this
trailer took because a I'm confused and
B if that's really the message they want
to send out like [ __ ] cool I'm a
little vexed by that but um yeah my main
concern is just like I've yet to see a
serial killer biopic really nail it and
have its priorities in the right place
yeah I'm I'm kinda which element which
element is it really gonna go down you
know yeah and I feel like Henry is a
good earmark cuz Henry is like a phi is
like a really upsetting movie but it has
kind of a split between the shocking
violent part of his being a serial
killer and just like this weird
lifestyle kind of seventies esque thing
and i like the idea of what maybe some
of the courtroom stuff in this movie
will do and i'm curious as to how they
handle the murders because what i would
say to this trailers credit is that
there's only really one visual you know
sequence we see of an ostensible murder
and so maybe it won't take every
opportunity to be like yeah yeah I've
already won I mean I like the edge to it
of exploring the idea of why people like
Sombra zodiac okay and zodiac is not
really about this because we never found
out who the Zodiac killer was so you
can't do a biopic about who the Zodiac
killer is or
black dahlia killers so what zodiac was
cool about that is it's about people's
obsession with a serial killer and how
it essentially destroyed them internally
over the course of several years and the
idea of exploring why people might have
been obsessed with like view Ted Bundy
in this like fascinated will mad to size
portrait yeah it's interesting to me I
just I kind of don't want to sit through
a movie that's making an argument for it
and if the move that's doing that that's
I have more of a feeling that trailers
to me see this
you say a lot we're talking this is [ __ ]
that gets cut in choosing a tone that
doesn't ever recontextualize so it
mostly looks like it just wants to have
yeah and yeah if if the movie is trying
to treat it like that I would be put off
by that Alfie
Kia says why are you both so ugly I mean
nedick's genetics and also you know like
agile I'm sorry you're clearly with your
profile photo you are a prime example of
what our look should aspire to be like
clearly you must be so attractive for
you to show off your handsome good looks
that much I will get a haircut just
because you suggested that Benjamin
Cabos I don't do anything until people
instruct me in the comments so if you
want me to do something just comment it
and I will live my life by your standard
oh thanks Lisa more teaming Lisa doesn't
think rug we think we can both be a
charming serial killer you're talking to
both of us right I will as more all
right Charlotte since you said thing
last I don't get Erica yeah what's your
opinion do you see Mark III Dark Horse
all the way man it's still 87 people
here we gotta get this going and
is going until we drop too few crazy man
well the the viewers on a live stream
I've noticed say I try not to get
discouraged up by it it's the people
always hop in and out of a live stream I
do it I don't ever sit down I've always
longer than the things you spend actual
time on YouTube doing thanks Steve I
really did my best on that movie fights
and what was cool is I learned a big
lesson on in that of like it's not it's
more about than not so much about
winning it was it really was like a
Rocky Balboa moment for me or just like
the amount of respect and praise I still
got for at least putting up a good fight
with the champ that's what I was hoping
for for dad to say like just that was
the hardest he's ever had it worked was
like if I was asked if that was the
reward you went the disparate Rider hat
and weird way of it's like it would have
been great to win but in a weird way I
feel like him saying that to me was more
rewarding than he holding the belt in
him being upset ya know for anything I
learned this game from you I became a
fan of this show because of you so to
hear that is actually what I could have
asked for that was the main thing I
could have wanted and to have such a
straightforward trajectory into this
championship I mean you jumped back into
the legal like the beginning of last
year then just kind of you know worked
your way straight up and I gotta imagine
that you know if you got a lose a
championship to somebody it ought to be
to the person and then to get the champ
you know giving you a compliment is like
yeah yeah really was intimidating kind
of like play anything against buddies
are also very very nice guy yeah because
he's also got that like calm like
directness yeah you know which is a
little [ __ ] hell of a listener like
taking notes nobody
he wasn't actually even writing anything
you were saying it was just word time so
you were just kind of scribbling just
that I think sometimes I just hell yeah
it's like thought processing yeah
business to keep your mind kind of clear
I know we said the 15-minute mark would
only be here for ten more minutes but
let's make this a solid ninety-nine one
minutes a solid 90 out of here John is a
heartthrob
rock pirate obvious oh yeah I saw this
on the high sea free Polly's waffles or
pancakes Greg you're a breakfast guy
please I'm I would say pancakes yeah
yeah definitely say pancakes yeah that's
too many pancakes for sure for sure yeah
yeah oh my bad
any tips on losing weight trying to lose
room for my sister's wedding next
October who this little finger this is
good for men and women to apply ah it's
all up here first
[Laughter]
good timing
I appreciate you about stick my finger
down my throat which I did to lose
weight no I would I would I would
definitely say well everyone has a
different body type first off I had to
learn that you know not just because one
diet works for someone doesn't mean
another diet work for someone else but
it primarily is what you eat but you do
have to exercise and some people think
you got to go like intense with
exercising but it could start off with
just walking for something as simple as
walking for like 20 minutes a day it
consistency is more important to
intensity one act of discipline affects
all acts of discipline as skinny as John
is now if you like I remember through
like junior high and all through high
school looking at John's photos as
fascinated because he had this like
crazy like weight
actuation thing that happened and then
it was a couple years ago where you kind
of just like stayed skinny I slimmed
down and I just got there
yeah I just kind of stayed there and but
at him and I have like different eating
habits for sure like as I as I worked
out like five to six days a week which
involves a lot of weight lifting now and
so I like I was like a weird eat pattern
yeah you like once and then tacos at
night I don't have the greatest yeah
I'll have like a pastry and a coffee in
the morning and dinner at night you know
you know what I'm going to give you some
advice in Reverse rego you have to know
why you want to lose weight first that's
that's the that's the oldest turning
factor for anyone's would falling the
channel 4 you'll know that for years I
was a lot heavier okay I was a lot
heavier at least like 40 to 50 pounds
heavier and the thing with that of
course that entire time I wanted to lose
weight you think I was happy of course
that entire time want to lose weight but
the thing is I hit a point where I
figured out why I want to lose weight
because the thing is you're always gonna
have obstacles presented to you where it
is they always tomorrow excuse and then
when you get to a certain point of why
you got to do it then you you eventually
it's like because nothing has meaning
unless nothing really has meaning
without like a solid motivate yeah and
we assign the meaning for everything we
assign it you know it's one thing to go
I want to be healthier why do you want
to be healthier for me I personally feel
like I'm sharper I feel like I'm more
creative III feel like I do a better
like like so yes teams remember for
movie fights yesterday I was the first
thing I did was I meditated and then I
worked out like I worked out really hard
because I'm like releases endorphins how
so you feel sharper I feel more relaxed
so I'm gonna do that and like there are
many wise as to why I consistently work
out now there was always the motivation
to lose weight now it's um now I don't
really focus on weight loss it's like
sometimes I lose weight sometimes I gain
weight like literally last we
I was I was ten pounds lighter but it
doesn't show on my body because there's
always like a weird thing with body with
uh with weightlifting and then there's a
weird thing with like water and take it
so looking at the scale can like psyche
you out and make you think if I got a
fatter with them like what then people
are saying it's confusing so you just
got to know why you want to be healthier
that that's the main thing yeah I don't
know why what the benefits are a lot of
the time when people want to get was do
want to get rid of something I'll let
you say shot I'm sorry I just got a
Mitaka so much yeah a lot of the time
when people want to get better at
something because they think what they
currently have is a problem they usually
focus a lot on researching why this is a
bad thing and what it can lead to and I
think that's important super important
to know that but I also think it's
important to look up the benefits of
doing something what what the that way
you have a hope and a positive outcome
to look forward to as opposed to it
don't want to get diabetes I don't want
to be fat I don't want to have a heart
attack it's easy to focus on all the
things you don't want but you have to
counterbalance that with things that you
want instead yeah and that's a big
important part of their life you'll
forget you have to know the negative
effects and then you have to know what
the positive benefits are by committing
to it and so knowing why is is the most
supportive thing you can do with
anything in life really but if you want
some reducing weight knowing why you
want to lose weight or be healthier
that's like free you can be shallow
about it in the beginning if you want
Halen's a Lindsey Lane hey if you want
to know about it in the beginning uh
like for the wedding like just be honest
with yourself do you want to feel like
I'm better looking are you single and
you want to meet someone at the wedding
yeah like if that motivates you enough
as your why then [ __ ] go for it and
just keep that in mind do you know yeah
well I think one thing that can help
also that I've just found over time is
even though my eating habits aren't
great one thing I've learned is that if
you find a certain amount of things that
you don't mind eating there
frequently that are kind of in line with
you know your goal that's that's why I
eat tacos for dinner most nights because
I'm like this is pretty simple in terms
of what I'm actually putting into it but
I can make it taste really good I can
get a little bit of variety and what I
decide to dress it with and I have it
portion controlled and it's all set up
so in that way you know if you find a
couple though and I think your diet
throughout the day is pretty you know
like a lot of the time and then you'll
you know have a cheat on weekends or
whatever yeah and watch your movie I
feel like as much as it doesn't sound
like fun to get on a routine of eating
that can also be a big help and I've
lost and I've lost weight in multiple
ways throughout my life some of which
have been healthy and some of which have
been less than healthy but when I was
you know in the healthiest version of
that that was a key elements that I
found certain things that I didn't mind
eating every day yeah and and just kept
those things around and that also helps
you with your budget too because then
you wind up kind of having a similar
list all actually actually yeah like I
the weird excuse I always hear with
people's saying like the tie it's
expensive to be healthy I'm like if
you're disciplined enough it's actually
so much cheaper to be healthy yeah maybe
like it really is if you can like learn
to cook from home like as I that used to
be my excuse all a minute I used to be
like that's why we get like [ __ ] fast
food all the time
yeah it's cheaper it's quicker and it's
hard it's more expensive to be healthy
because I care so much about taste but
if you can get inventive like for me you
know yeah thanks Michael Michael B is
here with some mommy
well that's the thing Lisa though those
tacos each one's different man I dress
them all different ways up with
different ingredients in each one like
yeah I get it like variety is key and
I'm a child of variety I guess I've
learned to kind of build fun foods out
into specific occasions more than
anything but uh you can still variety
also just what's up masturbates good to
see you I will have to check your
Instagram posts I'm terrible at using
social media but it's always a pleasure
to have you with us yeah I like you man
I'm not aiming to become an Instagram
model I really do it because I feel
better yeah yeah
are you really Peter north and
but yeah yeah we're gonna we're gonna
sound off right now but hey thank you
guys to everyone who's been here we the
prepping movie fights is it can be kind
of a stressful experience always leading
up to it and then you kind of have to
let it all go before you're about to
play it's kind of like acting like you
do a lot of homework thing I'll let it
go when you're doing the scene and and
and that when I so like movie fights on
Wednesday was you know I got the
questions of like 7:30 p.m. was like
3:00 a.m. and then and then I had to
carve out the whole day so we got a lot
there's like stuff I got to catch up on
editing we got patron to do is you gots
a lot of things to shoe for patreon and
a lot of things to honor write a
contract so yeah we got a lot to keep
going but thank you guys for being here
we like doing the live streams we do a
fun you know we find them more fun and
we like I don't know I like doing more
conversation based things yeah and I
like I enjoyed doing the read someone
asked me together a Gregory Bullock at
patreon asked me like do you genuinely
do you like - and I took generally do
like interactions I'm like yeah most of
the time I I do like doing the reactions
I wish more people stayed after the
reaction but the fact that matters they
don't and then we get lumped in this
category of we all we do is [ __ ]
react oh yeah that's just not true
yeah look that hate comment doesn't
really faze me anymore because I know
but that's not true just like how you
didn't watch yeah but like seeing
discussions like this is like when
you're live on the spot or like doing
movie fights I love doing that because
I'm like I told you that's so it's
always just another chance to prove we
can do more than just react to stuff we
don't know that's gonna be good
so yeah for the few people like out of
the thousands of subs we have for the
few people that watch us based off that
mmm percentage
thank you for watching here oh yeah
awesome thanks to Lisa martini for
subscribed and Lisa thanks for being
here
Lindsay thanks for being here all you
guys masks I is master be-all of the
constant interactions and to all the
people who contributed in the studio
now you've been Bom Nicole aim London
great love you guys but yeah we got some
[ __ ] to handle miss check us on patreon
if you can and we'll catch you guys soon
and through
[Music]